donc il a confirmé donc aux enquêteurs
qui consommaient de la cocaïne depuis
l'âge de 20 ans il a 54 ans donc ça fait
34 ans qui consommaient de la cocaïne il
ajoute il a ajouté que depuis deux ans
ça s'est empiré depuis 2 ans parce qu'il
a découvert une nouvelle drogue la 3 et
même si dérivée de la cocaïne très
addictive dans les injections augmentent
la libido il a vous consommez aussi donc
de la vodka prendre beaucoup de
médicaments dont des antidépresseurs
donc ça fait un terrible mélange depuis
des des des
mois et des mois maintenant
concernant les cures de désintoxication
et suivi médical il a avoué avoir
complètement lâché il y a un nom après
avoir suivi 5 cures en 5 ans donc
forcément pour lui il disait que les
cures ben ça marchait pas il a déclaré
au magistrat je suis complètement
catastrophié d'avoir mis en danger la
famille que j'ai percuté je suis obsédé
par ça le bébé qui est mort je prie pour
que les autres personnes restent
vivantes
j'étais inconscient de prendre la
voiture sous stupéfiant je le fais très
rarement
je suis dangereux à cause de la drogue
comme il voulait dire je suis chez
quelqu'un de bien il faut que mon
rapport à la drogue soit résolu que la
drogue soit bannie de ma vie il vous a
envoyé un texto qui un SMS qui
correspond à ce qu'il dit aux enquêteurs
un mois avant il voulait envoyer le
texte l'élément qui était quand même
très étonnant c'est que bon vous savez
comment c'est un spectacle va avoir lieu
il y a une cantine les artistes sont là
les techniciens sont là etc et on mange
un peu avant le spectacle et
donc il y avait une bouteille de vin
pour les autres la technique etc et je
dis à Pierre tiens si tu veux prends
prends un petit verre de vin oui mais ça
va pas mais jamais de la vie terminée
donne-moi un coca zéro donc quelque part
il y avait déjà un élément de ces
problèmes qui commençaient peut-être en
tout cas ils étaient les efforts pour
déjà
boire plus boire François donc c'est
c'est sûr alors Michel quels sont les
dernières infos aussi sur pierre alors
parce que là on est revenu aussi il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sortent
aujourd'hui encore comme vous l'avez la
sœur de Pierre Palma doit assuré aux
enquêteurs qui son frère était endetté
auteur de 250000 euros de l'argent que
l'humoriste devrait aux impôts à
l'URSSAF et à son producteur à un Gilles
il y avait une sorte de frénésie de sa
part d'achat de drogue faut savoir que
la 3 MC c'est à des effets de courte
durée donc on est en manque on en prend
on en reprend c'est moins cher que la
cocaïne mais il y avait entre guillemets
un budget d'achat de drogue qui
augmentait de moins en moins que
lui-même a estimé globalement il a
estimé ses nécessités mensuelles à 6000
euros
on peut avec Benjamin on pense que c'est
peut-être beaucoup plus beaucoup plus et
un total de dettes de 250 000 euros à
tout le monde voilà et des revenus dont
il disait qu'il n'était entre guillemets
que dû à ses droits d'auteur à 5000
euros voilà pourtant il avait travaillé
récemment c'est vrai les derniers mois
il avait travaillé mais c'est des
budgets des participations à des
émissions qui financièrement lui
rapportaient pas assez et donc il y
avait une sorte de course terrible je le
dédouane pas mais à trouver de l'argent
pour acheter de la drogue c'était ça ces
derniers mois alors on l'a rappelé ici
plusieurs fois un pire Palmade avait
déjà été condamné dans le passé pour
consommation de cocaïne en 95 le
procureur avait requis 4 mois de prison
avec sursis et Pierre a raconté son
passage devant la justice dans son
autobiographie disait il est comment
dire qu'un tribunal c'est comme le
théâtre de la vie c'est totalement idiot
de dire ça et ceux qui le disent ne sont
jamais retrouvés face à un juge parce
que là on a beau essayer de se cacher de
se pincer c'est la réalité point et
peut-être la prison au bout du chemin là
Michel Marie il avait été condamné à 4
mois de prison avec sursis ça va jouer
ça ou pas
ça va jouer pour le pour la récidive
c'est ça c'est la question qu'on se
posait hier il me semble ou avant-hier
sur la récidive mais récidive sur
l'usage de stupéfiant mais pas sur
l'accident donc est-ce qu'on tiendra
compte de
uniquement de la récidive de de stup
c'est fort probable mais Michel j'ai
besoin de payer on parle pas beaucoup de
quelque chose mais cet enfant
qui a donc respiré avant de mourir ça
veut dire que maintenant c'est fini pour
Pierre maintenant on recettes à domicile
involontaire donc maintenant il est
parti pour 5 ou 10 ans de prison enfin
c'est dans un autre monde là on va pas
le juger avant le non mais on est passé
de quilles blessures à homicide
involontaire on est dans un une
qualification qui est grave évidemment
très grave et la mort de cet enfant
c'est très grave cet enfant adore un
vécu 30 minutes 33 minutes donc il est
mort des suites de cet accident ça c'est
en l'état on peut pas aller beaucoup
plus loin mais on peut dire ça alors
pour répondre à Mathieu sera-t-il jugé
la question est provocatrice mais
sera-t-il jugé c'est-à-dire est-ce que
ces avocats plaideront peut-être
l'altération du discernement moment des
faits voir l'abolition ça c'est une
première question la responsabilité et
oui ça responsabilité ça c'est une info
ça veut dire que la drogue peut
peut-être considérer comme une tualité
n'est pas conscience maintenant
gouvernement avait légiféré pour que
quand on commet un délit ou à fortiorer
un meurtre en ayant pris consciemment de
la drogue on est plus cet exemple mais
néanmoins ça peut se plaider deuxième
élément qui sera très important
l'expertise de la voiture on en parle
pas mais ça les experts vont se succéder
pour examiner la voiture est-ce qu'il y
a eu un problème à la voiture et cetera
donc tout ça sera pris en compte il
risque effectivement 10 voire 20 ans si
la récidive est perdue mais il faut
savoir que en matière de délai routier
en France en général
on condamne pas énormément il y a une
certaine clémence ce sera tout l'enjeu
du procès exactement
tous les jours
on a plein de cas tous les jours comme
ça
on parle toujours de la peine maximum
il est en cours effectivement si tout
est tout est reconnu une peine allant
jusqu'à 20 ans mais c'est vrai que dans
la pratique judiciaire
on est en dessous de 10 à chaque fois
bien en dessous de 10 voir bien en
dessous exactement
une enquête pour trafic de drogue oui
parce que ça ça n'évolue pas trop mais
on voit que lors de la saisie même le
chien qui reniflait en entrant dans la
maison de Célie en bière c'est entre
guillemets centimal enfin il a il paraît
quand même les enquêteurs qui étaient là
on sentit des odeurs de stupéfiants de
produits donc il y en avait énormément
une cocaïne très fort
une cocaïne très forte donc beaucoup de
drogues retrouvées est-ce que c'était
des achats pour sa consommation ou
est-ce que derrière tout ça il y a des
dealers un trafic etc c'est le deuxième
volet de l'enquête exactement et là qui
va avancer grandement parce que les
saisies contrairement à ce qu'on pensait
au début à ses liens en bière ils ont
saisi beaucoup de stupéfiants beaucoup
de produits et sur la détention d'image
pédopornographique ça pour le moment la
prochaine étape
ils attendent quoi pour le pour
l'entendre en fait ils attendent qu'ils
soient physiquement que les médecins
autorisent son audition d'accord donc là
c'est de prendre combien de temps c'est
un certain temps comme disait un artiste
un autre qui était quand même c'est ça
qu'on arrive pas ça c'est
apparemment il est plutôt dans un état
psychologiquement détruit de regrets
comme on le voit dans le ce qui sort de
ces auditions mais les l'état de santé
ne sont pas totalement dramatique voilà
la question maintenant effectivement sur
la pédopornographie c'est que quand les
enquêteurs l'entendront peut-être en
garde à vue de 48 heures ils veulent
avoir déjà plein d'éléments pour qu'il
puisse confronter à plein d'éléments
voilà ce sera une seule fois rappelons
le 40 il a la télé il voit tout ce qu'on
dit est-ce qu'il a à la télé je sais pas
s'il a la télé il est il a le statut
détenu donc les détenus ont la télé donc
possiblement il peut avoir la télé il
peut pas avoir de visite sauf à passer
par le juge d'instruction
il a le statut de
détenues j'ai pas vu de télé
ce qui est fou c'est quand on voit le
texto que que je vous ai communiqué
c'est effectivement de voir que il nous
dit la toxicomanie a détruit ma vie
c'est-à-dire que il est presque passif
de ça c'est-à-dire que il en est presque
la victime et il le dit c'est-à-dire que
effectivement sans le savoir
on apporte peut-être une une défense
sans savoir ni sur le vouloir
à palmat qui nous annonce que
a détruit sa vie comme s'il en était le
spectateur le problème c'est que les
victimes ça elles peuvent pas l'entendre
de Pierre Palmade même si voilà voilà
foncer mais les excuses et ils s'en
fichent totalement il a la télé
non mais c'est incroyable ça c'est
vraiment l'importance du jour donc il a
la télé donc il voit tout ce qui se dit
sur lui dans toutes les émissions